thank you and this is joint work with
Christian Wulff Nielsen okay so they do
spin-offs is that sometimes you don't
really need the entire graph in some for
some algorithmic purposes we might be
willing to settle for a spot graph that
approximately preserves the distances in
the original graph and special used in
many disability applications you know
some examples
okay so let's consider this example and
assume we want to find a spanner for
this example we want to find some spots
up cough that approximately preserve the
distances in this graph so if you took
the following blue sub graph you can see
that every edge every two nodes that are
connected by an edge in the original
graph now have a path of its most two
blue edges so the differences in this
blue sub graph is at most twice the
distances in the original graph and in
this case we say that the stretch of the
spanner is two so the formal definition
of multiplicative spanner is the
following so we faded the sub graph H is
the case when our spanner with K such if
for every two vertices S&T the distance
between s and T in the fab love H is at
most K times the distance engine
okay and a very well-known theory
Montespan us is that a one can
efficiently efficiently construct a 2 K
minus 1 Spanish man who is 2 K minus 1
stretch with this number of edges and to
the 1 plus 1 over K and based on a GILF
can just would conjecture by elders this
trade-off is also conducted to be tight
ok so if you believe the girls
contractor you get a lower bound of with
this trade-off sorry here I also said
little month so how do we get it how do
we get this algorithm how do we get this
result so there's a very simple greedy
algorithm that achieve this bond for pop
for parameter ok we want to K minus 1
slash so if we just do the following we
just K we just get this trade-off of 2k
minus on stretch and n to the 1 plus 1
over K number of edges so we simply take
all the edges in the graph all of them
sort them in some increasing order or
non decreasing order and then we examine
one by one and for each edge UV that we
examine we take the edge UV to the
spanner if the current distance in the
constructed spanner between U and V is
bigger than 2 K minus 1 the weight of
the edge okay so I should be not how to
say that we already get by by
construction we get a 2 K minus 1
stretch ok because for every edge we I
don't have an alternative path of length
2 K minus 1 to eat em all we take the
edge okay and I'm not going to show it
but it's not how to say you know it's
not how to show that this algorithm also
produces a sparse graph the number of
edges here is at most n to the 1 plus 1
over K and the way to show it is to show
that there are no there are no small
cycles in the graph
ok and then please ulema Akutan and the
chose
that if there are no short cycle in the
graph then also there cannot be too many
number of fetches so this simple
algorithm get already get the conjecture
optimal bounds of 2 K minus 1 extraction
and to the 1 plus 1 over K number of
edges ok so counting the number of edges
is one one measure for the sparseness of
the graph we can also think on other
measures in one running natural manger
is the weight of of the spanner the
total sum of the weights of all the
edges in our spanner okay so in this
talk we will focus on the weight of the
span on we will try to minimize that so
what can we hope for with respect to the
weight of the spanner so clearly if we
just want connectivity we need to pay at
least the MST so we cannot hope to get
something better than the weight of the
MST and actually if we believe the gives
conjectures and we can also get similar
lower bond saying saying that we cannot
hope for better than pink into the 1
over the K if we want to K minus 1
stretch we cannot hope to get better
than n to the 1 over K times the weight
of the spanner okay so that's the best
trade-off to K minus 1 stretch and this
weight that we can hope for and with the
lightness of H is defined as the ratio
between the weight of our spanner and
the MST so the best lightness we can
hope for we still can - one stretch is n
to the 1 over K okay so let me mention
some related work on this problem so I
will mention you only the works on a
general graph so this polymer was also
studied a lot actually in a in AI for
other special families of graphs such as
geometric Lydian in
the bond the doubling dimension okay so
here are only going to mention the works
for a general Goff's okay so in six
needs to be it will shown that if you
just use the glitty spanner that we saw
is 2 K minus 1
stretch and then this is the lightness
that you get you may be better but they
show a boundary this is at most the
lightness that you get later it will
shown that actually if you're willing to
pay a bit more in the stretch not 2 K
minus 1
but another factor of 1 plus epsilon in
the stage then the greatest experiments
already give you a much better likeness
of K times n to the 1 over the K okay so
a natural question is can you remove
this k oh do we need it so recently this
game showed that you can actually it's
not essential having this fact Oscar
here and you can get something slightly
better you can get the grid it's panel
itself with a much more involved
analysis it already gives a lightness of
K over okay and in this work we we shave
this cake completely and we show that
with we show a different construction
it's not a gritty external anymore and
we show that you can get 2 plus epsilon
K stretch with this number of edges and
with likeness of n to the 1 over K okay
so if you believe the gulf conjecture it
optimal up to the wireless epsilon
factor here in the stretch in there for
the rest of the talk for simplicity i
will show a much simple construction
does not remove the k completely but get
a low K factor here
okay and we will leave to claims that if
I'll have time in the end of the talk
I'll prove them for now you will just
need to believe me so the first claim is
that we can always reduce to the case so
okay so say this is all MST and again we
want to compare yourself against the
weight of the MST
so the claim says that we can always
reduce reduce to the case where all the
weight in the MST are 1 okay we assume
that all the weights in the spinner is
at least the minimum weight is 1 and we
without earth of generality we can
always reduce the case well all the
weights in the MST are 1 and the idea is
just to round each edge here and add
some dummy nodes in the middle to get to
get this nice property okay so okay so
when if a lifetime in then I will show
it it's not completely difficult ok so
that's the first assumption that we make
the second assumption that we make is
that we only need to take care of
weights after 2k ok so again if I have
time in the end I'll show it but then
the general idea is that the clouds of
weights are actually easier why so say
that I have to handle much larger white
so what can I do I can take my MST I can
always just add the MST assume that my
MST is in my spinner
it doesn't cost much and I can take the
MST and use the estate to kind of group
the nodes into some clusters such that
in each such cluster the diameter the
diameter in the MST is small ok so just
using the way the edges of the MST I can
traverse from every node in a cluster to
every other node in the cluster using
just a very small diameter and and then
I can just consider each chapter as a
node and if the weights of
the edges are very large then I have to
go with a very large edge and get into a
cluster for every path for a path and
then I have I will do some detail here
but the detail is so small compared to
the weight that I didn't lose much okay
so I can always so for larger larger
wider I can just take larger and larger
clusters and then then we will get a
geometric series so the odd part is to
handle up to 2 K so I'm slightly
cheating here because it's told that we
need to handle a only the Clutton edge
weights are easy easier but we also have
them st edges that are of which one so
and we need to use them so if I go into
a cluster with which one and then do the
detail here then actually I can get a
very bad stretch so we will need to wait
to play a bit with the waves of the MST
too but that's the general idea
okay so for the rest of the talk or all
the top will assume this to assumption
that the edges of the MST are all one
and that's all the weights in our less
graph is at most 2k so and any claim
that a simple claim that we will use is
the following
so let's consider now will MST again all
weights one with always one we can
always petition the nodes so we get a
parameter R we can also partition the
nodes in the MST into clusters with
diameter are there in M in this number
of clusters so we can always have n
roughly and 2n over our clusters of the
armature in M AR so why we can do that
so let's assume it's easier to assume
that the MST is just a path
even though it's not necessary okay so
if the MST is just the pass it's very
easy to do we can just take the fill
style edges cluster them together and
then take the next I'll edges and
cluster them together okay so we will
get that way that the diameter in each
such cluster is R and we have in over
our clusters so and actually if the MST
is not a path if it's denser on that
it's a it's actually just more
convenient for us okay so actually the
worst case if it is when it is a pass
you can also get the same claim even if
it's not a pass but for simplicity I
think that the MST is a pass
okay so that is a filter a see how we
get slightness of K times n to the 1
over the K and later we will see how to
improve this K tool okay okay so again
we assume that the weight Fiona all one
and that we need to handle weights up to
2 K so we will have just K buckets in
each bucket we will handle weight 2 to
the I to 2 to the I plus 1 okay so we
have K buckets and we will show now how
to handle the bucket I and how much we
need to pay to pay how much how the
weights that we need to pay for the
edges that we take for our spanner to
handle edges in this bucket so by think
anything or satisfying edges in this
bucket so for every edge what we need to
show is that we either take this edge to
the spinner all we have a short
alternative path to this edge okay so we
have if we have this poverty for every
edge we will get a spinner
okay so now we are not only looking on
edges in this bucket between 2 to the I
and 2 to the I plus 1 so basically what
we can do is we can use the previous
claim and just cluster take the MST and
cluster the nodes in the MST into
clusters of roughly this diameter
epsilon times two to the I okay so we
will have roughly n over this number a
number of clusters let's ignore epsilon
factor so we have roughly n over two to
the I number of clusters each with this
they are written and now what we can do
we can just take each such diameter and
contract it consider it think of it as
one node and so we have this node now
and now we have all the we add to this
contracted graph all the edges of weight
between in this bucket and we know now
the edges of the MST between the
clusters okay so we have all the
clusters here of this diameter and the
red edges in this bucket and now what we
do we simply invoke our greedy spinner
on this contacted graph okay so what do
we get so likely that the stretch is
fine so why the stretch is fine
so the gain of spinner promise me that
for every edge that I did every edge
read edge I also took it all and if I
took it's great and if I didn't take it
then it means that I have some other
paths of length two Kayla roughly 2k of
edges that I did talk today to the
spinner but the sum of the weights of
this edges is at most 2k minus one the
weight of this edge and so the weight of
each edge here is in this bucket
but I also in order really to get a path
in my spanner I also have when I enter a
class that I also might need to do some
small D term here in order to take the
next edge but the bit on here we made
sure that it will be very small compared
to the entering edge so the edge here is
2i and the detail that I need to do is
only epsilon 2 to the I okay so the
details all the details do not add much
to the total length of the path between
these endpoints
okay so overall I
that I get a good stretch with this
additional one perception factor to my
spanner so we only need to show now how
much weight did we pay for this level
okay so how many let's see the number of
nodes the number of contacted the nodes
that I have in the graph that I
constructed here is the number of
clusters that's the way we could suck at
it
which is this number roughly roughly n
over two to the I I am the greatest
panel
don't tease me that it will return me a
spanner with this number of edges each
edge here is of wake to the eye so I
need to multiply it to multiply it by
Tuesday I and if two terms cancelled by
another and we get that the weight of
the greatest panel for this level is n
to the one plus one over K and we have K
levels so for all levels we can get this
weight this likeness is K times n to the
1 over K because they must even any
questions ok okay so now we want to
improve that to improve the K factor
into a low K fact on so previously what
we did is the way we constructed the
class down we we kind of constructed
them independently for each level I week
infected we constructed different
clusters we didn't really care about how
they left one another but but we can I
we can simply also do it in in a bit
more I have a graphical way such that
say that this is our initial clusters
for the first level then in the second
level I can I can take laughter such
that each cluster is just the Union
disjoint union of some clusters from
previous level ok so if again I was our
MST the line then indecision the first
clusters the
class now we can just simply take say to
is adjacent clusters and make them
together one cluster and we can continue
this way hierarchically okay so now each
cluster here is just a union of some
class tells a from previous level and
each previous level castoffs belong to
only one cluster in the next level okay
let's so now for simply let's assume now
that the first diameter that's the first
diameter of cluster that I have is K
okay I hope that it will be clear in a
second why
okay so let's so let's this cluster of
all a of their metal Ashley Kay let's
consider now let's try to satisfy only
edges of weight one okay so actually
satisfying edges of which one is easy
but we will do it of course for every
level later okay so now I'm trying to
satisfy only edges of weight while and I
want to use the clusters here for for
this purpose so if I got lucky and every
cluster here have so now I'm looking at
all edges between clusters in the in in
this level and I remove multiple
multiple edges okay so I don't have
multiple edges I just pick one of them
so if I got lucky
and the number of edges incident to each
cluster is constant and this happens for
every level so this level I will look on
edges of which one here edge of weight 2
4 and so on so if this happens in all
levels then I'm actually done so why so
let's see how much I pay how much weight
I pay in this level so I have roughly
interval I have roughly n over the K
clusters here right and the the way it
and for each craft I assume that I have
only constant number of incident edges
of which one
so for each class that I actually pay on
the off one wait so overall for all
clusters I pay n over K wait and we can
do that similarly for every level and
since we have only K levels then overall
we will pay only off in a wait okay so
if I got lucky and the number of
incident edges is always constant for
every level then we are done okay but
what do we do now with edges with high
degree clusters okay so if this cluster
has many incident edges of which one
then we couldn't do this trick okay so
okay so what do we do with high degree
class stuff so let's go back to the
properties that we need actually from
this cluster so what portal they do we
need we we need a property that we don't
have too many clusters in every level
right for this level we wanted only if
the Danakil is out we wanted to have
only an overall number of clusters and
the second property that we need is the
diameter okay so this is the two
properties that we played off the plate
of between the data and the novice
clusters but now if you give me a
cluster that have many incident edges
touching it then I can actually use it
so I don't care how many num how many
the number of nodes in each class I only
care about the diameter if you manage to
give me a cluster with much with many
more nodes but with the same diameter
then it's actually great I can click
most of the not most of these nodes as
if they disappeared so that's what we'll
do here if I have high degree clusters I
will use all this incident edges
I will now contact these clusters a bit
differently by you by exploiting this
high degree clusters such that I will
take this cluster with all of these
incident edges and I will make it a
class of again all with small diameter
but with many more nodes okay so before
that say I could only take two clusters
and merge them together to get a cluster
of roughly 2k now I can take depending
on the apartment I can take ten of them
okay so more than half of them
disappeared so now I will I will I will
kneel the class of their disappeared to
do something else so what else can I do
so you know that half all the low-degree
cleft of fear are already covered and
for the high degree I know that at least
half of them will disappear in the next
level so what I will do is I will take
say that we are now handling this level
we take all the high the glee class
those here and again we changed the way
you constructed the clusters we use if
this is a heavy class selves we take all
its incident clusters and merge them
into one small diameter cluster so now
we have less clusters here um and I will
take all the clusters so one attempt to
do it is to take all the clusters here
now the heavy class dolls put them aside
construct a new graph with this with
this heavy cluster and take all the
edges incident to to them that both
endpoints are in both endpoints aren't
heavy clusters and now we can just
construct a greedy spinner on this
cluster okay so half of the nodes here
will disappear so I'm authorizing every
node appeals in only one spinner so I
won't pay too much so on every node on
average I want I want to get into the
one plus one over the K weight so for
every node Oh
times log n ok so for every no they can
pay roughly and to the one over K so if
I contract expand on here and on average
every node I paid the number of nodes
healed
and to the one over the K then I'm done
so I'm okay okay so I am doing that like
that we won't get a good stretch though
right because the diameter on here is K
and the edges that we are looking are of
weight one right we already have this
gap so we fell contacts s panel easy
this panel on this graph I will get a
terrible stretch of K squared okay every
edge every incident edge of which one -
the clutter I might need to do a little
here of wet K okay so I don't want to do
that but what I can do instead is so
let's say that now we are looking on on
a level I so instead of looking on on
high degree class tells on level I and
put them aside
I will look on one high degree clusters
of level I I will go low K or a bit more
than low K level back for which that
cluster I know it's a union of some
clusters of level I - locate here and I
will took this small clusters that are
contained in this big heavy clusters and
I will put them aside okay and now I
will construct a spanner on these
classes so you will go roughly lokay
levels such that if I want to satisfy
edges of weight to to the eye
I will go enough level back so the
diameter is epsilon - today I
and now it will contract a std spanner
on this say on this graph so now the
study is fine because every edge of 2 to
the I I just do a small D to of epsilon
to do the I ear so I don't pay much so
now the wait they're stretchy is fine
and the white is also fine because again
we we saw it before the the two to the I
here and the two to the I here cancel
each other ok so every node inside this
cluster a peels in only one sped up half
of the nodes here faithful day as a half
so on average every node appear on only
one 2 spanha it will spells and the
weight of this total spanner will be the
number of nodes here at times and to the
1 over k again because these two factors
as we saw before cancel one another ok
any questions that's a construction with
the low K factor so why do we get low K
so we had to go before if we just
confine the greatest panel on this level
then we didn't get a good stretch but we
know that on the legs level half of the
nodes here will disappear but now this
is not the case anymore because we go
locate level back so it will take this
nodes here to disappear only they will
disappear half of them will disappear
only a low K after low key levels so for
each node here for each cluster here we
can open the first time the first time
it contains in in a heavy cluster okay
so say this nodes this for this nodes
these are the first time the first level
they are contained in a heavy cluster so
we know for for all levels below they
did not appear in have in any heavy
cluster or in any spanner so this is the
first time I actually add the note in
these clusters to a spanner and I know
that after lokay levels they will
disappear so they have only half of them
have only local level
chance to opinion if spanner and after
locate levels I know that half of them
will disappear
okay so that's the general idea with
getting the low K times n to the one
over K any questions on the construction
okay and to get rid of the low K we need
to do something a bit differently we
need to look on all this locate together
and do something a bit more complicated
instead of doing that for every level
separately okay so I see that I have
enough time I will just show the two
claims that I am that I used in the
construction so the first claim that we
used is that that we can always reduce
to the case without changing much the
number of nodes and the weight we can
always reduce to the case while the
weight of the MST yeah all one okay so
let's say this is the weight of the MST
and let's define W prime to be the
average weight in the MST that the just
the sum of the weight in the Emma stay
divided by n minus one okay so now we
can look on every edge and round it up
so first of all all edges of face all
edges in the spanner of this weight we
can easily handle so why we can easily
handle all edges of that weight
we can simply take all edges of this
weight and constructed levy spanner on
them
that's one cost much it will cost n
times in a way one of one plus one over
K times the weight here which we are
willing to pay okay so say that we don't
have edges that all I want edges are of
weight larger than that we already
satisfied all of them all of the edges
of weight less than that so now what we
can do is to take every edge in G and
just round it one run its way to the
nearest multiply of W prime so that's
one change the weights very much but why
because now we assume that all our
weights are very big so I just add W
prime for every edge so I didn't change
much so now every edge is a multiply the
weight of an edge is just a multiply of
W pine and now what I will do now I will
okay so that was say let's look on an
edge in their mistake so before it was
two W prime plus one now I round it up
to three w prime and the next step what
I will don't just fold away just to fold
the edges of their mistake I will take
each steps edge of the MST and I will
add some dummy nodes here to make every
edge of weight W Prime so if the weight
he leaves three W prime I will add two
dummy nodes and the weight of each edge
now it is W prime and you can see that I
did not add too many number of nodes
here so by rounding up every edge in the
MST to the nearest W prime I could only
double the the weight of the MST so
adding this dummy nodes we can show that
you you only you only added maybe n
number of nodes more okay so we didn't
change much the weight and we didn't add
too many nodes and now we have that the
damage they are all of uniform weight
now we can just
divide everything but W Prime and if you
won't change anything so now we reduce
to the case well the weight of each edge
in the MST is 1 okay and in the next
claim that we used is that we only need
to take care of weights of 2 K 2 to the
K so I said before what we can do with
larger weight let's see it slightly more
formally so let's say that now I want to
handle a edge weights between 2 K - 2 k
plus 1 ok and in general I will do it to
every 2 to the I k 8i a to the 2 to the
I K plus 1 so not we can do is we can
use the previous claim of clustering and
cluster we can partition the three now
our ring is again of which 1 because we
reduce to this case we can partition the
tree into this number of clusters with
this diameter and now so I have now left
in each class that I just contact one
node so I have leg I have left node now
and the diameter of each cluster is
small compared to the weights that I'm
trying to cover though but actually now
we also have the weights of the MST of
weight one so I cannot just like end
them into the constructed graph like
that because then I can I can use a
weight one and do a huge dito here and I
will get a terrible stretch so what we
do is we just take all the MST edge
weights and the chrism increase them to
2k
okay so that's so let's see what the
weights of the new the weight of the new
MST so the weight of the newest is the
number of nodes times 2k which is again
roughly often okay so we didn't change
much the weight of them Estates stayed
almost the same actually we also we a
bit increase it to be n over epsilon but
let's ignore exelon factor so we didn't
change much the weight of the MST but we
change the number of nodes and
previously what we pay is the number of
nodes to one over K times the weight of
the MST so that didn't change much but
that's changed and we can show that if
we just sum over all buckets of two to
the I k2 two to the I KS 1 then this sum
is just a geometric series so just to
summarize we got what we showed here is
that low K times n to the one over K
lightness in the paper we showed n to
the one over K lightness with this
number of edges and this stretch and we
have here a dependency on epsilon okay
in the number of edges we don't have a
dependency on epsilon so the the
question that remains left is that can
we improve the stretch 2 to K minus 1
remove the 1 plus epsilon additional
fact on stretch that we get
so far the toilet was fresh log n we get
constant times there MST is there right
yeah and the previous video was just the
log n log in time yeah about the
construction time instead of the greedy
spender could you use any spanner
construction that is the trade-off mmm
this domain is the running time this is
dominant sliding thing like for the
sauce that I mean that's what we know
like efficient constantly a construction
force panels we know how to do only for
the grybyx pedals so like if you don't
want the fact okay
more efficient construction of spin-offs
they have the fact okay so if you use
them so for stretch to K minus one you
showed that the best the badness was it
was a bit more we had two K minus one
times one minus Epsilon but yeah you can
plug it for 2 K minus one ah oh no bulk
area you can plug the from power metals
here to get to K minus one and you will
get a better a better lightness than n
over K epsilon we just need to calculate
it do that equal to K minus one that
that will give the best bounce you will
get a dependency here exponentially in
Epsilon